we've been testing Oppo phones for years
including the X6 Pro and our current
favorite the find N3 flip as well as our
OS which works incredibly well so we
partnered up with Oppo to show off their
new color OS 14 software and some of
their new really unique features using
their new Reno 11 Pro 5G which is by the
way very very nice especially this
interesting material that almost looks
like this cool 3D look but getting back
to color OS 14 that's installed and
updated on this phone it's packed with
new underlining infrastructure and
algorithms bringing you new features and
upgrades like the new aquamor design new
smart efficiency AI features smooth
performance updates and safety and
privacy upgrades so let's get right into
the first part which is the aquamor
design the whole UI has been changed to
feature the new aquamor styling as you
can see right here they've updated all
of the little images the logos
everything looks nice and clean with
subtle gradients they've also updated
all of their sounds with the aquamor
style so you can see right here and I
really like all of these themes because
it's almost like a nice soft and
soothing sound and style across all of
these aquamor themes like this is for
the ring tones and for the notifications
I really like the clouds one it almost
reminds me of like a Nintendo game it's
really nice they also have this really
cool new aquamor coloring feature which
actually adapts a different scenarios
like the phone status and the time which
matches up the colors to the context of
what's going on so you can see right
here you could actually have it
automatically adapt your alarm sound to
the current weather you can see Rainy
snowy it changes the sound with these
nice soft aquamor tones moving on they
also have the new Aqua Dynamics feature
which will show off information about
different apps at the top of your screen
so for example if I start screen
recording right here you can see that it
actually pops up in this panel at the
top of the display which is really nice
you can actually long press on it and it
pops up a bigger panel basically for
realtime status tracking of what's going
on so I could actually adjust this I can
turn off the screen recording I can
swipe it away same thing for the audio
recorder if I do that look at that once
I swipe away it pops up the audio
recording bubble right here at the top
and keep in mind that your notification
like your messages and other things will
pop up at the top of the screen with
these new aquad Dynamic bubbles there's
also a really cool new go green feature
within the always on display settings
which has this carbon footprint settings
where you can turn it on and it'll
actually show you which times you're
using less of the carbon footprint which
is really cool so you can set it just
like that and it'll show up on your
always on display and now let's move on
to part two of the cool new features of
color 14 and we have Smart efficiency
for example they have new gestures for
taking screenshots so if we swipe down
with three fingers like this it takes a
full screenshot of the entire display
which is really cool they also have the
really cool Smart Touch and extract
content tool where you can take a
screenshot and then click on extract
content then you can highlight text and
drag it into the file dock you can even
drag images as well which is really cool
moving on they also have their new file
doc feature which allows you to actually
move files across different apps for
example they have their really cool
smart image matting feature which lets
you identify different subjects like
this cutout tap on it hold it and it can
actually pick it up and release it and
then look at that you could save into
your file dock just like that that's
using both new features at the same time
so check this out I'm going to cut out
this little Oppo Reno 11 Pro box and
there you go it just went into the file
dock they also have a bunch of cool
features in notes so I can actually drag
and drop this go into the notes app and
Bam I just created a note dragging and
dropping it which is nice and now let's
move on to another really cool feature
part three for color 14 and we have
smooth performance with oppo's new
Trinity engine which basically allows
you to multitask with different apps and
it makes it a lot more smooth because it
balances and manages your memory
resources giving you long-term very
smooth performance for example you can
go into the phone manager app and
optimize all of your different settings
you can clean up anything extra that you
have and they do have a couple of new
features where you can optimize and
balance your overall systems performance
including defragging your system in
storage the first one I want to mention
is the ROM V ization feature which can
actually clean up and free up your
storage by compressing your app and file
data down using things like compression
defragmentation and memory acceleration
so you can see I could go into clean up
storage right here you can see how much
compression there is and you can
basically press this button to clean
everything up and clear anything that's
extra as you can see I have zero bytes
of apps that are currently compressed
because this is a brand new device that
I just opened but we can go into the Ram
vitalization feature which actually
boosts your RAM performance by revamping
the underlying Android Ram mechanism and
boosting efficiency to keep apps running
in the background for up to 72 hours
this is actually a really cool feature
because on a lot of smartphones apps
might only be lasting a couple of hours
or maybe the next day everything's reset
and refreshed 72 hours with color RS 14
and you can see how everything basically
stays open right where you left off they
also have their CPU vitalization which
basically uses the Trinity engine to
maintain an optimal balance of
performance and power efficiency in all
use cases throughout the day they also
have new smart charging features which
you can turn on and it'll actually use
AI to kind of detect how you're using
your phone throughout the day and change
the charging you can even limit it to
80% manually if you want to to kind of
slow down the battery aging of your
device or you can rely on the AI if
you'd like there's even Arctic mode
which will preheat your battery
intentionally when you're going to be
charging to optimize it sort of how like
EV Vehicles do it in the winter where
you want to get it warm so it charges
and doesn't damage the battery and now
let's finish off with number four which
is safety and privacy they have this
really cool new picture feature keeper
which is going to prevent apps from
misusing the permissions for your photos
and videos so you can set it and you
don't have to worry about anybody using
things that you didn't allow them to use
so you can see right here the permission
manager go to the permissions and you
can see which apps actually allow you to
use your photos some of them will say
while in use some will say not allowed
at all and you can make some to allow
all the time and now they also have this
really cool autop pixelate feature which
can automatically pixelate sensitive
information within your screenshots and
pictures switching to Auto you can see
it detecting oh there you go it detected
my name but you could actually touch and
hold more areas right here I just
pixelated the email address and the name
and the photo just like that in the
screenshot they also have a lot of
settings like for example you can go
into the screen refresh rate and you can
always set it to high keep it as
Standard Auto Select I love having it in
high because that's the best smoothest
120 HZ really really nice they also have
a bunch of new text editing features
like for example you can highlight you
can underline and a bunch of other
things and now they have a really cool
new phone link system that'll let you
connect your Oppo phone to Windows PCS
to sync your messages and much more so
with all that said and tested I've got
to say I'm very impressed with oppo's
new color OS 14 it's very nice and
smooth it's concise it's smart and I
love some of the features that we tested
like for example that auto pixel 8
feature was really cool the new aquamor
sounds ringtones the colors the whole OS
is very smooth I love the new
performance features and everything and
you guys let me know your favorite
feature down in the comment section
below if you enjoy this video you can
click above to subscribe and check out
one of those two right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next
video